PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
And we're back.
We have ordered some cameras, so
we can all stay safely at home
and still serve you the
Lowest Latency News.
I am Priyanka Vergadia,
and welcome to "This Week
in Cloud."
This week, we're talking
about Service Directory,
column-level security in
BigQuery, and the new SRS Book.
Service Directory is
a managed solution
that provides a
service-centric approach
to connecting to your
cloud infrastructure,
from Google Cloud, to
GCP Marketplace Services,
to your own applications.
It provides
real-time information
about all of your services
in a single place,
helping you publish, discover,
and connect services,
regardless of their deployment
environment or platform.
The new BigQuery column-level
security controls
are designed to help
organizations govern
their data in Google Cloud.
You can now define
policies on data
that differentiate
between classes,
helping you meet
compliance requirements,
meaning you can grant
access to a table
while still barring access
to any sensitive data
in that table.
A rapid response virtual agent
is a customized contact center
AI virtual agent
that can respond
to the increased
demand for customer
support due to COVID-19.
Using this template, you can
quickly build and implement
your virtual agent, providing
additional customer support
over chat, voice, and social
channels in under two weeks.
Check out the short
video to get started.
If you are looking for
a new book to read,
I've got you some good news.
"Building Secure and Reliable
Systems" is now available.
This book is a page-turner
of advice and experience,
and is sure to become an
essential read for anyone
responsible for the security and
reliability of their systems.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link
in the description below.
Any thoughts or ideas, leave
us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.